welcome to another episode of not too
deep I'm your host grace Helbig today is
a very exciting episode as they all are
but extra exciting because we have
comedian writer producer director
American vandal Jimmy Tatro with us he's
in the real broseph Simi Valley that you
can watch in full season two on Facebook
and he's just an all-around great dude
with a great voice and a great attitude
and a skyrocketing career so hear all
about it on this episode of not too deep
with Jimmy Tatro Tatro petrol teatro
it's it's been an issue for a lot of us
hey friends I want to talk about a new
podcast that you should check out called
just between us it's hosted by
codependent besties and New York Times
bestselling authors Gaby Dunn and
Allison Raskin just between us is a
variety show that's all about brutal
honesty female friendship and giving
unsolicited advice who doesn't love that
gabbing Allison bring laughter to life's
toughest and most ridiculous situations
by asking thought-provoking questions
playing games and dipping into serious
topics about relationships mental health
money sexuality you name it
but listen you might not know them but
you're gonna feel like you're just
between them listen and subscribe now to
hear all new episodes of just between us
wherever you get your podcasts we're
here we're doing it Jimmy you're here
finally I am this is very exciting
thanks for having me of course
congratulations on the real boroughs of
Simi Valley thank you
I watched all of the most recent season
because I'm a real housewife obsessed
human okay how did this get created were
you into Real Housewives at all no okay
well then you did a great job mimicking
it yeah I think we did watch a lot of
Real Housewives which seasons what [ __ ]
franchises which a lot well because we
were watching we I mean but the idea
came from like there was just so many of
these Housewives shows and we would joke
about the ridiculous incident of this
the randomness of the cities yeah you
know they have like potent
yeah and I don't even how to pronounce
that do I pronounce that way Potomac
yeah yeah but that is good right
where is Potomac DC okay you know these
rhetorical ish questions and I'm gonna
have an action okay that's good
but no I agree with you cuz now they're
doing like Dallas and Atlanta and they
started with like the OSI which is a
very like strange area I mean I get the
OSI make sense live Orange County okay
yes yeah but then once you're in Potomac
yeah and all these ridiculous cities we
were like we need to just make fun of
this and we've always just made fun of
just reality shows yes how stupid they
are yeah they are and like nothing could
happen but you've so much footage that
you're able to pretty much make up any
story line you want yeah you film these
people all day you have enough footage
and sound bytes to edit it together to
make any storyline you want and they the
way that they cut the my favorite part
of the reality TV shows is that you can
audibly hear when they slice up
different sentences and put them
together sometimes sometimes it feels
like an editor on those shows has a lot
to do but sometimes you feel like oh I
heard him they got lazy that she's like
I can't believe what she did most people
don't catch stuff like that exactly yeah
so then you know they do that they use
all the sound effects from the dramatic
music and so the first season was just
kind of we wanted to just make finer I
did a video a long time ago called how
to make a reality show where it was like
a three a two minute video where nothing
happens yeah and then it was like now
let's make a reality show and I used the
same footage but I like Reata today my
blurred stuff that wasn't meant to be
blurred which is how they actually make
like peace and then I like bleep yeah so
it seems like you know there's all this
beef that isn't real but I was just kind
of where the the concept came yeah and
we would watch a lot of Real Housewives
and then we started realizing wheelhouse
this just was not the tone of this show
oh really
cuz Real Housewives that tried to watch
some Kardashians I tried to watch some
Real Housewives but it was just
everything was too nice too nice you
know and that wasn't really the vibe of
the show we were doing and then we found
Vanderpump rules
yeah and it's like I don't know like you
watch the Kardashians they're doing real
stuff so a lot of exactly what we're
doing right now sitting on two chairs
talking at each other with a camera on
right that's all they do then they shake
their salads for a little bit and then
they talk about something that we never
get to see you happy well then I guess I
must have just seen the season finale or
something because there was so much
going there to Kanye's show there are
these photo shoots I'm like this is not
I can't watch this for but then
Vanderpump like I would send the editors
clips of Vanderpump and be like the way
that this is like excuse that as oh yeah
well your your template for now that's
great until I can get into all these
crash zooms and shaky camera angles that
make it look like people are getting
pushed and things are being like that we
did some of that yeah yeah that's great
it was there any specific cast member of
Vanderpump rules that stood out to you
guys hmm like Jax is very much a see me
Jax could fit on on real bros yeah it
was funny because I I met scheana oh at
the Super Bowl it's like what two weeks
ago that's a normal sentence but so I'm
at this bar club uh-huh and my friend
walks in with her and I was like I'm
like kind of drunk I mean I have to just
tell her yeah that you know I've watched
her show for inspiration she's gonna be
the kind of person I would assume would
love that
yeah and and I told her and she was like
you know it's crazy she's really nice
and I was like like you're nuts like I
love your work you're nuts she was like
wait why no not how many nuts nothing
okay well I guess I haven't gone to the
part of the show where you're not not
change my opinion ya know it's so their
shows are so interesting we had Stassi
on the podcast before the blonde one
that doesn't work at Sur anymore oh
she's the one who's like the most nuts I
think and also she's the greatest
smartest brand builder of all of them
she's got a book she's got her own
podcast she's actually super smart and
really funny but she like knows how to
brand herself which they all have sort
of figured out and I had like a full
fangirl moment when she came here was on
the podcast I had to pretend that I
wasn't as big of a fan as I actually was
and I was like Stassi Schroeder is here
oh my god I know too much about her this
is weird the show is just I mean there
was one moment where I was watching it
and it was like that guy I think Tom
yeah I want to say to him
and he's one he wants to go to Vegas
with his boys for a boy's trip his
girlfriend is pissed because it's her
birthday he wants to go on and boys trip
during her birthday yeah and the whole
appeal of this Vegas trip is his buddy
was selling him on we're gonna rent
these trucks we're gonna go to this this
yard where you can like destroy stuff
with these trucks she gives him this
whole heartfelt spiel about how her
birthday's are hard now that her dad
ever since her dad died I am oh like
emotional thing and he's just like dead
serious is just like babe I get that but
like we're supposed to go to this yard
and we're gonna be bulldoze and [ __ ]
with trucks there's no way you actually
just said that after she just said
everything to you
but they do they do it's it's real I
hate to break it to you I had to run
back to watch that like five more times
so how was shooting this season burst
the first season because you did this
season for Facebook now yeah does that
make it any different I made money
instead of I mean season one I paid for
and I knew I was gonna lose almost all
my money yeah but I was like right when
PewDiePie said all those anti-semitic
things and all the advertisers dropped
off Facebook
oh interesting or YouTube sorry YouTube
okay yeah so right when season one came
out I was like no revenue right when I
started dropping season one it was like
five days prior with when PewDiePie said
all that stuff Wow
and I was like why did this video only
make a hundred bucks yeah yeah it's got
like a million views and I mean like I
said I wasn't expecting to make money on
but also if you're putting cuz that's I
think an interesting thing for anyone
that is working in this world especially
like in the digital world that like when
you want to make bigger things you can
throw up it's okay I swallowed some
coffee down my earhole when you want to
make stuff you can make you know YouTube
videos on your own but if you want to
make these bigger production things yeah
they cost money and if you don't have
people investing in it you have to put
up the money for it people don't realize
that like the really critique we got on
the season with people like put it on
YouTube oh really
on the Facebook stuff yeah oh okay you
think I'm just gonna I don't see that's
the kind of commentary I don't
understand why it's like it's just a
different tab device amount of work you
just type in Facebook instead of YouTube
same cost still free like you cannot
complain about free guy like you can't
you cannot say [ __ ] if I put this on
this is free yeah you can critique it
and say it should be this place of this
place but it's still free yeah it's like
this place is free this place is free
this one um I can make money on it this
one I would lose all my money on it so
like the people that I said this in like
one of the descriptions of my videos was
like if you're really at this point
still past that it's not on YouTube like
what are you rooting for you can't the
platform right you're a fan of Google
Google supporter you support Google over
the actual show itself if you're not on
Google if you're on Facebook I'm out
yeah you're a [ __ ] Google fan Wow
it's just cut to videos of them burning
their laptops these diehard Google fans
what has been because you've been making
videos since college hmm so that's how
many years it's like mmm
okay what's been the most hilarious
critique that you consistently get I
know you get a lot of like it's just
always people to do more frat stuff yeah
like yo I've been out of college for six
seven years now I have no interest in
doing anything yeah I don't get that as
much anymore but like I mean that was
kind of what I got famous for on YouTube
do you know douchey frat videos yeah it
becomes your brand and personality and
people don't realize that this is not
who you are right generally I also made
the mistake of using I was playing like
this character sure but I used my real
name oh yeah : use Miranda as she was
like using her real name all the time
people would be like oh that's actually
her where's your lipstick yeah yeah yeah
good for me it was just like you know
how do I explain myself they'd be like
what do you mean you're not that guy is
your name not Jimmy no it is are you not
a frat well no I I am right so what's
different just where is the line but
what um okay and then you so American
vandal also congrats amazing very cool
very fun and as I I
we're not even like close buds but I
felt like oddly proud of you as like a
youtuber to be like see people on
YouTube are talented and good and like
can cross over because you know I'm sure
you've heard like the stereotype
so many times is like we're just kids
that make videos in like our oh yes
basement dwelling somewhere and that
there's only reason that we get
opportunities like that is because
they're completely it's a numbers game
or it's a social influencer game in some
way but I was like no he's good he's a
good there's good ones but then there's
also sure but I was like he's
representing for the goods that's great
it's really proud of you
and you got a Critics Choice Award
nominee I did yeah next to Sean Penn was
he also nominate Robert DeNiro honestly
the most crazy
what's the reaction to that I was shook
I was uh I mean that was I was really
truly not expecting like a nomination of
any kind and I knew we were making a
like I knew the show we were making was
was really good yeah but it wasn't until
I saw it
yet I realized how good it was because
like so much of that was him just the
way it was edited yeah and they did such
a great job with it and but I still
wasn't really thinking like it wasn't
like I was acting in it like if I do
well enough you know maybe get nominated
for something no but I mean just being
on a list with those people was just so
I was just flattered you know crazy and
I brought my mom to the Critics Choice
Awards freaking out she like like she
was just like touching someone's dress
like she was just like she was like calm
it was just like so like oh my god like
I love your outfit and it would just be
you know like Margot Robbie
this woman has like all these feathers
coming out of her dress my mom's like
just like I'm touching them with looks
me and the lady like turns to her right
and it's just Angelina Jolie time
opportunity that's the reason you get
into acting
that moment she was at the end she was
like kind of like tentative around me
and then she laughed and the next day
it's time you know about her while later
she was like I said II know if you were
gonna be upset that you lost upset that
I lost
Ewan McGregor won like that's come on
they don't pissed about that yeah like
he was like all the names and then you
think they're gonna give it to the dick
guy okay we're gonna take a really quick
break and we get back we have a bunch of
ridiculous questions for you and then
we're gonna get into some Twitter
questions the Internet yeah aspiring
minds want to know we'll be right back
with more nacho deep OkCupid is the only
dating app that finds you someone based
on who you are and what you're into the
OkCupid dating app asks you fun and
meaningful questions that matter to you
so you can be seen by people who are
going to be into you from questions like
would you pay an extra five dollars to
guac or are you too close to your family
did you vote in the last election you'll
see tons of answers that lead to great
conversations and great dates with
people who feel the same way that you do
you can tell people about your favorite
album your last great trip or your
favorite podcasts hint hint nudge nudge
wink wink something's in my eye sorry
and let the love roll in on the OkCupid
dating app whether you're looking for
that person to join you on a long walk
on the beach or a short walk to the pool
bar that's more my speed they're waiting
for you on the OkCupid dating app start
the new year by meeting someone who's
into what you're into you on the OkCupid
dating app download the free OkCupid
dating app and find the next great date
today this episode not to deepers
brought to you by hum nutrition they're
all about making you look and feel your
best each specific supplement packs a
combo of
potent ingredients designed for specific
aims like clear skin boosted energy or
fuller hair and is backed by clinical
results hum focuses on preventing
concerns and long-term care and repair
not damage control and covering up their
quote in
our approach to beauty goes beyond
skincare regimen alone to give you great
results
hums products are a sustainably sourced
non-gmo and free of soy gluten
artificial colors and preservatives plus
a lot of vegan options try supplements
like the daily cleanse hair sweet hair
growth gummies uber energy and more if
you aren't sure what you need go to humm
nutrition calm slash get underscore
started to take a quiz and get
personalized recommendations from homes
team of registered dieticians they've
sent me some of their products and I
have to tell you they're really great
they offer a monthly vitamin
subscription that's affordable flexible
and convenient all the things that
actually make self-care way better and
attainable to do so that's something I
support go to home nutrition comm slash
get underscore started for your
personalized recommendations and get 20%
off your purchase with code grace that's
humm nutrition dot-com / get underscore
started and code grace okay I always
love to hear because I literally went on
an audition yesterday and I I'm so bad
at them and they make me so confusingly
nervous if you have a terrible
auditioning story or just when the is
was weird I went in for one and it was
the same day they booked me for two like
nine page auditions on the same day
nakta back and one of them was for the
entourage movie and I was like that's
the one I'm gonna focus on yeah yeah and
the other one was like it was for this
movie I don't think I should say yeah
but it was like you know all the
description was like tall handsome like
you know basically just for Aquaman no
it was it was just this was like an Anna
Kendrick movie I think I was supposed to
be there was for the love interest who
is it just said like tall handsome and
like other thing okay and like I'm not
saying you know I'm ugly but I'm not the
tall handsome guy that they're looking
for you know they're looking for like
you're like I'm playing casting director
in my brain right now
I walk into the room I'm gonna go with
someone else I can be honest with myself
they're looking for a Liam Hemsworth
type gotcha yeah I'm you know the funny
best friend yeah in that situation so so
I go in and I'm like very not prepared
and I'm like in the hallway out like
just trying to like go over the lines
and I get in there and the casting
director has the whole scene memorized
which you just like doesn't even have
his script and he's acting which is not
usually you know and I'm like just
trying to remember the [ __ ] yeah and
he's making me feel like I literally
said the first line and he was like it's
not that's not it that she's not it like
cuts me off on line one I was like okay
well this is definitely not going my way
like I should have just left but he was
like do it more you know you just like
coming off it really mean okay well and
I like tried it again and like you cut
me off on like line to this time and I
don't know just the combination of the
dark I having everything memorized me
not having everything yeah yeah and
being a role I was never gonna get in
the first place it's a those auditions
are the worst that they're just so
degrading and also that guy clearly
thinks he's the director that it's like
his time to play director before the
director actually gets in the room with
the casting and like go through everyone
it's the worst I hate it so so much and
I always get because I'm taller and
blonde I get like sexy mistress and I'm
like that's not at all what I want to do
nor I know the type of girl that's gonna
go in there and nail that and I'm gonna
go in and be like oh I love you and it's
gonna be so confusing for them because
I'm just gonna be like hating it the
whole time there's more one more
selective now like I wouldn't go in for
that now that's good yeah do you have a
dream role but you would want to play X
I know you don't do frat stuff anymore
so do you have a dream like type of
character dream like yeah I mean yeah I
have been I have been swatting all of
the frat
[Laughter]
no I I would like to do like an action
movie Oh that'd be cool I think I could
do an action movie like if you were to
do like a buddy cop action type of film
who would you play alongside of or who
will play alongside of you wow that's
tough I know I mean you should like I
should have mentioned that you might ask
that going into this
keep in the back here and we'll come
back to it yeah I would like to do like
a I'd say like a transporter Jason
Statham type thing okay you know very
cool I saw my agent I was like if Taron
Egerton is gonna do all like the James
Bond type roles
give me the Jason Statham it can be the
you know the pretty boy I'll be the more
rugged one you also you have a
comedy-drama film with Hugh Jackman
coming up yeah yeah role in it it's
Allison Janney okay Hugh Jackman and
then a bunch of other really good actors
will not remembering right now did you
get are you in scenes with Hugh Jackman
no I'm only in tuned with Allison Janney
oh I hear she's awesome she's amazing
yeah just very funny yeah it was a
little intimidating to you know act
across from the Best Supporting Actress
okay but it was I mean I think it'll be
a pretty good movie it's it's a it's a
true story it's about the there was this
whole I think it was 2004 these two the
superintendent and the accountant of
this School District in Long Island
siphoned like 12 million dollars out of
this school oh [ __ ] yeah it's a true
story
Wow part in it I play Allison Jenny's
son cool yeah cool
that's super fun
so that was a cool of the cool thing it
was the first thing that shot that was
on film Wow interesting
did you shoot here in LA no it was in it
was in Long Island oh very cool that's
super fun how authentic yeah have you
had a fanboy moment then going to like
Hollywood parties and going to different
events where it's a person that either
you wouldn't you didn't get yourself
worked up enough to say hi to them or
you said hi and it was like an
afterthought of God did I [ __ ] up I've
definitely there's generally been like a
lot of people that have seen and been
like oh my god yeah like I've met I was
at breakfast with some people and Bo
Burnham showed up and I've been a huge I
guys I think Bo Burnham absolute genius
yeah he really is but we have we have a
mutual friends so he was always like
gotta meet Bo I'm in Bowie's walk down
oh my god
and he's hard to miss he's like seven
feet tall yeah but he was I think he did
see an American vandal so he liked that
well it's cool the coolest thing to me
is when people that I really like have
seen American band all yeah here's my
biggest fan blow moment okay here we go
I was at his SNL after-party yep and I
see Nathan fielder he was one that I
would be I couldn't go up and say hi to
him because I would [ __ ] up completely I
was just like oh my god his show makes
me laugh harder than anything I've ever
seen and and I'm like talking to this
guy and I'm like oh my god that's Nathan
Fielder and he's like he's like oh yeah
you're a fan I was like dude Nathan for
you I think is the best the best show
and he was like oh that's my show I
created it with Nathan and I was like
and I was like talking to him and he was
just like hey man like American man that
was great you were great and then I was
just like oh my god
that's cool and then I was just asking
him like all the questions I wanted to
ask about the show like how do you not
how do you keep a straight face
yeah so awkward so awkward and how much
do the people actually know vs. not know
and like oh god at that gym I can't sit
down and watch I have to pace the room
when I watch it
so the [ __ ] that he thinks of is just
like how the solutions he comes up with
- the issues that they impossible to
guess when the show starts where it's
gonna go like he goes at leas like side
bark like these tangents where it's like
he's all the sudden he's dating a
prostitute Stu what they're doing yeah
the episode where he's trying to get the
pie guy there's a guy there's never so
with a pie guy they always use it yeah I
mean I guess this guy's so pissed off
that I'm like why does this guy keep
coming back to this job I want you to
follow me for a week not him and oh god
it's so good
the coolest thing I'm at I'm going back
to real birds per second is it feels
like it's just a bunch of actual
real-life friends getting to make
content with each other it's like did
you guys all know each other before you
created the show or did you meet each
other like as you created the show I
mean I knew a new Cody I knew and I
tried a new Nick and Tanner they they
had done I did one video with them
before oh they did like a bachelor
parody where at the end I can't decide
between the two girls so I FaceTime my
boys and show them the people and they
were the two the two guys just one of
them to be like started so then I met
them there and I was like oh these guys
are really really funny yeah and then we
were casting wheel Bros they just
like obvious obvious obvious choices and
then the girls I knew Maddie and Monica
gray I knew like three of them because
like all the [ __ ] girls
yeah the batch girls I had done that
show yeah that's right
yeah I did that show like a week after
you had done it and they were all
gushing about how amazing you are and I
was like who is this person we did yeah
we did a sketch on that episode that
like went super viral yeah okay which
was a really funny one but yeah I knew
them from that I thought they were
really really funny but one of the girl
wasn't available so then she was like
you did my friend Colleen who's really
funny oh and Colleen that was great
she's the only plays Molly oh that's
awesome of the people one of only ones I
didn't know going in I knew Peter Gilroy
a little bit from like a thing we had
done but I mean I kind of knew most of
the people yeah
but not that well okay but I do know you
do now I'm gonna say it seems impossible
to go through that and not know them
after this no one talked to me where's
there a lot of improvising yeah yeah I
mean yeah like a lot of the little jokes
were improvised and I would like I would
want to do the first take the first
couple takes yeah like I wanted to get
it first sure no you have it then play
yeah and then we can play with it
because once everyone starts playing
with it things would just kind of start
like this is the storyline things were
just like they'd get really funny but
they would just start going this way
yeah so this is like okay which a lot of
that a lot of those moments are the
funniest moments in the show like a lot
of that stuff is just what feels the
most natural so you want to do it but it
just kind of can become a little bit of
a nightmare and edit when you have to
dress quilt everything together in order
to make the storyline that's making a
real reality television show exactly
yeah so you actually being truly
authentic to the genre yeah
I want it we I made sure to shoot it
with we did everything with three
cameras oh that's great because that
seems like everyone's performance shots
because I wanted people to be able to
talk over each other yeah and make it
all conversational so it was just you
should with three cameras everyone's
performing shots at the same time yeah
the only problem is for me to watch
three screens yeah
and monitor all those at the same time
and begin it that's intense you also who
is Christian is your like I wrote it we
wrote it the whole thing together and
you guys been working together forever
right yeah since college yeah since
college that's nuts
yeah we were in the same we went to the
same College cool and you guys dropped
out at the same time no he stayed I
dropped out gotcha
[Music]
and that's that okay here's a couple
random questions for you what's your
least favorite sketch or video that
you've edited so far or is there one
that you're most embarrassed about that
you two parter one that either you're
most embarrassed about that still exists
on the Internet or one that never made
the light of day mmm-hmm
I've taken some down you have yeah for
just cringe reasons cuz I I can't watch
them without being like Oh what are you
shut up I mean honestly the the fact
that I used my real name as this
character like really just kind of irks
me sometimes and I can't watch some of
these old videos without just like I
wouldn't know I don't want someone to
see that I don't want someone to be
considering me for something and then
Google Jimmy Tatro and she you know one
of these frat videos on the Internet
like at the time they were funny huh if
I had just called myself [ __ ] Todd
all that problems will be solved why
don't you make an episode where your
quote character changes their name it's
too late too late
a lot of the ones where I would rant
about stuff ah took a few of those like
I just I didn't delete them I just made
them unlisted okay so you can still
watch them if you have to link so that's
fair so there's still quote available
from still available they're just harder
to find but for casting directors and
producers you want to keep their eyes
off of them because a lot of them like I
don't know I'm like ranting about stuff
and I watched these videos I'm like who
the [ __ ] do you think you are I yeah I
haven't even I'm too lazy to even go
back through the archive of videos I put
up to find the ones that I know I'm
gonna hate horribly I just pretend I
live in blissful ignorance and I pretend
no one knows how to go back and look at
like 2011 videos nope fingers crossed
what's your most ordered item from post
mates I like that question it might be
the burrito Mexicano from tokaiya yeah
very specific I mean you could always
pull up the older can always get your
own receipts the old post mates archive
here was the last thing you ordered on
post mates then it was my favorite thing
about post mate says I have my name on
post mates is Dirk dockland that's oh
like every time they show up order for
Dirk my name is melody janitor that's
good yeah it's gotta be tokaiya it's
mostly took is a lot of kitchen 24
oh yeah 24 hours a day some might say
okay here's a question what's the bad
habit their friends harp on you the most
about if you have one I definitely have
one they'd probably be able to answer
this question a little better than I
want yeah I can't I can't think of what
it is right now my friends would
probably be like able to answer this
question right away
yeah then what's your biggest pet peeve
in another
human oh man people that are just on
their phones non-stop at dinner oh
really do you try to like um I mean at
dinner like if we're you know yeah
chilling on the couch no one's doing
anything yeah sure you know but it deals
you're at a table that's meant for
people to look at each other like in a
situation where it's like this is
hanging out we're hanging out now mm-hmm
just be present
join the conversation don't like I just
hate when people are like constantly
what's on here is more important than
what's here yeah you know it's just like
that's good for you if that's so
important then why don't you go do that
Oh drag whoever that people are that
dude yeah do you look at the is your
phone of the thing now I hate this so
much I have to figure out to turn it off
the screen time that you look at your
phone every week it gives you like your
report it is so sad right no wait just
like a phone thing now because I had an
app that did that Oh apparently in the
new update on the phone like once a week
you get this little pop-up notification
it's like your screen time for the week
on average has been this it's either
down this percent or up this percent
from last week and you can like set
timers on your phone that turns your
phone off after you've used it for a
certain amount of time like that gives
you then you just get cell matters from
the past yeah no way from memory turned
on like a two hour time limit for her to
use her screen she's like 11 a.m. i
screen shut off and I was like oh [ __ ] I
am an awful monster I downloaded that
app cuz I was trying to cut down yeah
and then I was it was right when I was
shooting this show hmm so like there's
so much downtime if you're after there's
so much downtime hurry up and wait yeah
you know and and I was like look at my
screen time there's like nine hours one
day I was like it was like eight hours
okay and I was just like how what yeah
so just disgusted with myself yeah
throwing the phone in the river that's
what I always say that's how you cut
down on your screen time just throw it
out there I just look I look around now
and it's like no it's not
they're not even in people's pockets and
no and I feel like break my own habit
I like biting my nails like I don't
realize that I'm doing it and I'll be
like looking at my phone going Oh
where's my phone occasionally and then
I'm like I'm an actual monster yeah this
is not okay
you know it's bad when you close
Instagram and then you open Instagram
right away and you're like what am i
doing like what is happening right yeah
what do you do other like what do you do
for hobbies do you have stuff outside of
Internet yeah yeah I like to uh I like
to draw really I have like this
whiteboard okay um it's very weird it's
actually this my phone background uh-huh
whoa holy [ __ ] it's a really weird
fucked-up photo that's cool though this
is yeah so you like illustrate yeah it's
just like good I know I like drawing on
whiteboards because you can kind of
erase some stuff yeah yeah but that also
makes it so like it doesn't last forever
right well I actually this one I don't
want it to go anywhere so I bought like
a clear spray paint I'm gonna solidify
oh yeah and put it on the wall I bought
a new whiteboard because I was supposed
to be for like writing yeah and
productive stuff until I filled it up
with this huge drawing and I was like I
can't really delete I can't erase I
can't really there's the internet can't
delete this okay
we're gonna take one more last break and
we'll be right back with no sorry to
bring you back into the Internet but
Twitter questions for you attack we're
not too deep
[Music]
to deep the all foam Lisa mattress is
new and improved featuring cooling LS a
200 foam for enhanced pressure relief
for side sleepers and their superior
hybrid mattress is the perfect
combination of foam and spring for
pressure relief and edge to edge support
Lisa's mission is to provide a better
night's sleep for everybody and from day
one Lisa set out to create a company
with heart that's why they donate one
mattress for every 10 they sell to
organizations that work and causes like
foster care prevention and to date
they've donated more than 32 thousand
mattresses through more than 1,000
nonprofits this is a wonderful company
with great products so I highly
recommend and you can get 15% off your
order if you go to Lisa comm slash grace
and use promo code grace that's le e-s-a
comm slash grace promo code grace
support for today's show comes from
bareMinerals creators of clean beauty
purity in formulation and uncompromising
performance have always been the guiding
principles of bare minerals because they
believe that makeup and skin care should
make your skin better not just better
looking this has been the bare minerals
philosophy since they began the clean
Beauty revolution in 1995 with their
best-selling original foundation which
offers creamy lightweight buildable
coverage that's naturally a luminous the
clean formula is made with only 5 good
for skin ingredients all minerals
including non-chemical SPF protection
makeup so pure you can sleep in it and
actually it will improve your skin over
time it's everything your skin needs and
nothing it doesn't for bare minerals to
be clean without compromise means good
for skin formulas with proven
performance like every bare minerals
product it's 10 it's 100% cruelty free
better yet both the original and that
loose powder foundation are available in
30 shades so upgrade to clean beauty
products use the foundation finder at
bare minerals calm to find your perfect
match first time customers will get 15%
off when you use the promo code not too
deep
that's bare minerals calm promo code not
too deep for 15% off your first purchase
bare minerals the power of
okay we're gonna get into some Twitter
questions but before we do I'm gonna ask
you the two questions I ask every single
guest that has been on the podcast and
good and the first is who alive or dead
would you most want to throw cold
spaghetti at probably don't jump good
yeah
that's a consistent answer that we've
gotten and that makes sense
I have not caught up with what [ __ ] he's
up to now Nate but that's a good answer
the next question is to tell us your
worst pants [ __ ] story or close call
but you can only use three words or
three small phrases sorry [ __ ] again my
worst what pants [ __ ] story or close
call so for but you couldn't use three
words or three small phrases so mine is
college jogging front lawn Wow
yeah mine is candidate Arden naptime
[Laughter]
sorry actually preschool naptime amazing
that you can remember that far back for
[Laughter]
my earliest memory I think I was like
you know three four Wow yeah yeah I
remember him like bringing my cat to
show-and-tell but you had a different
complete going over that I never playing
in the pillow room
I remember trading my action figures if
you like the three things are never from
preschool no in college yes or in the
pillow read to circle back to yours
okay let's get into these Twitter
questions someone to know is your sister
Laura single has your sister been
featured in videos and things she's been
in a car pool okay yeah does your family
like being in videos or do they they
yeah I think they don't mind it
explicitly said no yeah they're not
calling me like put me in more but if I
ask them they're usually down oh that's
nice they get recognized from time to
time from the ones they've been in do
they really yeah which is always funny
oh that's so sweet
how do they handle that my mom will call
me and be like okay it's almost no has
your voice been that deep since birth
oh yeah yeah this must be the thing that
a lot of people comment on all the time
yeah I mean it's not since birth I can't
imagine having like a three-year-old
that says its first words and it's that
octave I could be like oh mama horrified
I think I was like 12 when it got like
pretty low yeah cuz another one I was I
went up to college and my brother turned
13 or 14 when I was gone okay then I
came back and I was like Johnny boy what
happened to you it was startling oh yeah
but I would imagine I was around the
same and so yeah
his voice is almost as deep as mine but
not quiet really how deep is your
sister's voice same as mine but that's
funny that runs in the family
also are you I mean you were um you're
doing voiceover in an animated film yeah
how was that that was fun yeah I worked
on that for a cool four years oh really
yeah I I was doing like the scratch
track uh-huh which is just when they
hire voice actors while they're
developing the script
oh wow so I was just going in there and
the script was changing the writers were
changing the director changed Wow so I
was on the movie before the director and
the whole cast except for the guy UI me
and him we're on the scratch track
together okay and then everyone we were
working with got replaced by like LeBron
James channing tatum's and daya is the
movie out already
yeah okay I enjoyed it
yeah you say you didn't hate it no I
thought it was cool
I would honestly if I didn't I wouldn't
say that I enjoyed it but I did
there you go yeah are you doing more
voiceover stuff coming up I am yeah I'm
doing a animated
[ __ ] I don't know if I'm allowed to say
but well that's all you need to say
that's very exciting business someone to
know would you rather guest judge on
drag race or film a cooking episode with
Guy Fieri was the first one guest judge
on RuPaul's Drag Race okay I film a
cooking episode with Guy Fieri I think
I'm gonna go with the ladder guy yeah
okay with guy guy actually walked by me
two weeks ago at the Super Bowl and well
and that I was just like usually you
know someone can walk by yeah oh no he's
he's maybe I feel like one of the most
recognizable like what's a celebrity's I
mean his hair is like it's on fire it's
on fire yeah wear sunglasses behind his
neck it's such it's such a look walking
cartoon character if you guys do a
season three of real Bros I feel like he
is an absolute fit in some capacity to
cameo there yeah someone's dad yeah or
just as himself is very funny oh my god
Bryce's dad is like makes so much sense
of course your dad is dad oh I feel like
guy
that he's like a cool person that he
would be down to do something like that
sorry now I'm casting your fictitious
season three of this so just someone had
to look at a baby and say guy I guess it
is also a fun Google search is to look
at old guy Yeti before he became like
cooking channel or Food Network I Yeti
because he looks dramatically different
yeah a nose job yeah
know it he looks like an IT guy glasses
were on his the front of his head they
were actually like glasses then they got
tinted and moved to the back yeah he's
got like brown hair he looks it's
confusing it looks like he went to like
the witness protection program and they
were like let's bump him up
so let's know what's your favorite thing
that you've been a part of probably
American vanduul yeah yeah how long was
that whole process like from auditioning
to finishing rapping shooting um I
auditioned in like November mid-november
um and they call me back in December
okay and then we started shooting like
January 15th 2017 okay I think yeah yeah
and then it was like a month long to
film oh wow no it was it all in Los
Angeles yeah it was all in uh yeah like
a lot in the valley and the Pacific
Palisades Cole a little bit around here
that's awesome yeah it was just a lot of
fun and it was like I don't know it was
I think some of my best work yeah
hitting wise I didn't write the show but
they I listened to a podcast at the two
directors and liked what they wanted for
the show itself like after watching like
making a murderer and things like that
yeah
and like how they went about directing
you guys and like everyone else and it
was just really fascinating to hear how
much I like cared about you guys feeling
like you had a good performance and then
you felt like strong and your character
know like these seem like nice guys yeah
it was very cool did you get to
improvise a lot on that set
yeah that's great yeah they let me they
let me just like go and go and go
because we would do like before we even
did the lines they do improv takes first
Oh a just interview me like the kid who
played Peter Tyler yeah he would just
interview me for like they'd roll for
like an hour and he was just like asking
like questions and I would just be in
character yeah
answering them for you Lee yeah and then
we would do the lines and they still
made it in a way that like it pretty
much follows the script but then they
just like let me like say things in my
own way and they kept a lot of my random
improv like at the end there's this
whole thing where I'm talking about how
I'm gonna bring a pencil and I was all
just like a random tangent I went on and
they left the whole thing in them that's
awesome I mean that's a I think they
were saying that on the podcast that's
like some of these moments you can't
script and they're too good and they're
too they're way more real than if the
actor is just trying to act out
well that was why I think they they
wanted to do him first and they wanted
to just like Tyler did a great job
he was like has like a new book they
were like he came over prepared like
really took it so seriously was asking
questions that even them behind like in
video village or just like what oh my
god okay there's a lot of things that
like I wouldn't know the answer to yeah
then I would just like kind of stay in
character and be like I don't I don't
know it was weird because they would
like let you know what you know yeah
overall it was just a great experience
that's awesome that's very cool I mean
it comes off it was such it's one of
those things it I always say if I'm mad
at it while I'm watching that's a good
sign because it's like why didn't I
think of this why couldn't wasn't that
part of this this is so good a mad at
someone to know do you feel guilty or
happy after binge watching a whole TV
show with say eight episodes in one
night and why I don't know if I've done
eight in one night
I would say I feel accomplished is like
if I were to do that like I would have
watched this show like on my to-do list
yeah yeah be like that feels good to
cross it off what do you watch right now
I'm getting caught up on Game of Thrones
oh okay I was way behind yeah so my
haven't that seems like a lofty duty to
get caught up on it's a lot I just like
I know it's like the best show yeah but
I don't know I was i watch that and then
I just I'm the guy who hasn't seen
anything so every time I'm in a meeting
I'm just constantly getting yelled at by
I haven't seen this well have you seen
this I'm like let's not go down this
road let's just I think it's put a
blanketed assumption on this meeting
that I have not seen whatever you're
about to reference to my roommate now
every time he's like you haven't seen it
okay whatever I know that's I'm the same
way I don't watch movies and I only
watch like reality television because
it's just so easily digestible and
consumable and it's like radio you just
have it on in the background yeah and so
yeah people get very frustrated with me
but though they've learned that it's
like part of my charm that I haven't
seen something and what I actually do
see something it's like the most
shocking thing that's ever happened
everyone there's a lot of questions
about is there gonna be a real brosef
Simi Valley season 3 is that to be
determined yeah I don't think we're only
we know the answer right now I would do
oh do one more yeah but right now I
think Facebook is uh figuring stuff out
analyzing their data alright cuz it's
part of Facebook watch right uh-huh
which I've heard we've had a couple
guests on that also have like potential
shows with Facebook watch and have the
same sort of opinion on no one knows
what's going on yeah but I mean like if
I were them and this is the same guy
that wouldn't cast myself in this movie
I was talking about yeah I would pick it
up
yeah I definitely would pick it up I
mean I feel it'd be kind of dumb not to
yeah I don't know what they're doing
over there but also like the response
from like the minor and the amount that
I've seen has been super positive it's
been incredibly positive yeah and they
shouted great all the episodes of like
at least a million and a half years
that's amazing so got like character
accounts for all the characters that has
75 thousand followers that's crazy
yeah I don't know what they're doing
Facebook we know that you listened
actively to my podcast on a weekly basis
this is a formal plea for a season three
thank you so much
check it out okay someone to know do you
pronounce tattoo tattoo or tatay - I
think is that supposed to do
are they making fun of Teatro and Katra
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay and last one oh do you have an
inside track on if American band will
come back somewhere else I don't I don't
think so
you don't think so I am NOT a hundred
percent sure okay but Netflix didn't
pick it up and I think they control the
future
figure it out
Jimmy thank you so much for being here
yeah this was super fun and we're gonna
give you the gift that would give every
guest that's on the podcast okay it's a
personalized fortune cookie just for you
feel free to open it and read your
fortune if it's in there maybe perhaps
oh okay they're questionable cookies no
you're the guy who can you explain this
to people this is an overheard
conversation it was so ridiculous and
like this girl and her boyfriend you're
leaning against her car she's leaning
against the car boyfriend's standing
there and like there's a lot of foot
traffic on my
yeah tons of people a guy got shot down
the stream over that one yeah the nice
neighborhood but it actually is but
there's just like a lot going on um and
there's girls like weaning it's your car
and the guys like come on and she's like
no like and he's she's like do you know
how many times you've spit on my car and
he goes I don't a lot Mike that was the
extent of the conversation that I heard
the only time you spill my car I don't
and that was it and then that's the kind
of thing like I don't really want to
follow up I just want to live it all I
want to know thank you for being here
where can people find you online and
what you're up to if they don't already
know Facebook real browsers she knew
Valley mm-hmm and yeah I mean that's
where your socials are all just your
name I'm just at Jimmy on Instagram oh
yeah you got Jimmy perfect yeah awesome
well we're very excited for potentially
season three and for you and Hugh
Jackman to be in a movie together
can't you that's good so great thank you
again we'll see you guys next time
another episode of not too deep goodbye
2deep 2deep 2deep 2deep as the creators
of clean beauty Bare Minerals is driven
by a philosophy that makeup and skincare
should make your skin better not just
better looking that's why their
best-selling original foundation is made
with only five ingredients all minerals
for bare minerals to be clean without
compromise means good for skin formulas
with proven performance upgrade to clean
beauty products use the foundation
finder at bare minerals calm to find
your perfect match first time customers
will get 15% off when you use the promo
code not too deep bare minerals the
power of good not too deep is a
production of grace helbig incorporated
producer and edited by Melissa demons
writing by Diane Kang a production
assistants by Katrina Henning
post-production sound by Christopher
Bell and an extra special thanks to
Flula for the theme music
[Music]